weeping over the remains of Iran's top
military commander supreme leader
Ayatollah Ali Himani visibly moved as he
leads funeral prayers for his former
close ally hundreds of thousands of
mourners gathered to pay their respects
to general Qasim Soleimani killed in a
US drone strike in Iraq on Friday his
assassination is considered a
declaration of war by many Iranians
speaking at her father's funeral
the generals own daughter has promised
reprisals families of American soldiers
in Western Asia have witnessed America's
humiliation in Syria Iraq Lebanon
Afghanistan Yemen and Palestine they
will spend their days waiting for the
death of their children in the
parliament they've also been cries of
death to America the savage action of
the US president is considered a
military act of terrorism you ought to
know that this adventure will have
painful consequences for you and the
anger is spreading across borders in
Lebanon the iran-backed Hezbollah
militia has threatened to hit American
forces in the region meanwhile the Iraqi
parliament has voted to end the US
military presence in the country some
5,000 US troops are there officially to
help defeat so-called Islamic state US
President Donald Trump has already
warned Baghdad that it could be hit by
tough sanctions if it follows through
with this threat but it's Iran's promise
of revenge that's focusing mines Tehran
has already announced it will no longer
abide by the 2015 nuclear deal raising
the stakes even further I'm joined by
Atlanta bottom
a Middle East analyst who's with a
think-tank center for applied research
in partnership with the Orion welcome to
you know we saw a lot of anger in Iran
over the killing of a general Soleimani
when Iran talks about revenge what does
that mean we have to think it in two
ways there will be a short-term way of
revenge which is more or less like a
blood revenge or a vendetta which brings
American lives in the reach of Iran in
the Middle East which puts those lives
in danger and then there will be a mid
and long term revenge which will
actually actually focusing on rousting
the u.s. in the region of the Middle
East and that is a strategy that Qasem
Soleimani had embodied okay talking
about rousting the u.s. from the Middle
East now Suleiman is assassination in
Iraq has also led to a spike of tensions
between the US and a Baghdad what are
the implications of that I mean it's
it's it's not difficult to understand
how carrying out such an operation on a
sovereign and then hit and harming the
sovereignty of a country like Iraq will
will lead to these reactions
it's a parliamentary decision it's it's
not legally binding yet but it sets lose
a sort of sort of dynamics that are
putting again American troops in danger
in Iraq and can ultimately lead to the
ousting of the US troops from Iraq led
by Iraq and not by Iran and how
important is the presence of US troops
in Iraq well that's a completely
different subject matter that needs to
be discussed in fact the US has been
working together with Iraq and to some
extent with the Iranians to fight
terrorist groups to fight the likes of
of Isis to fight al Qaeda and other
groups and and for that matter equipping
Iraq in the equipping the Iraqi army
training them that has been the role of
the US but at the same time it has also
been accused of certain abuses it has
been targets of attacks by different
militias that are operating in Iraq so
there is a real mixed picture of what US
presence in Iraq really means and what
are the wider region I mean
one has a militia operating in several
countries as you said the this u.s.
attacked this targeted assassination
didn't only kill Qasem Soleimani but a
top iraqi commander Marty sorry and a
boo-boo Marty Mohandas and alongside the
lebanese actor like a lebanese
stakeholder an important person so they
will also be revenged sought by by these
groups and that is certainly something
that Iran cannot control and that's
another level that the US needs to be
concerned about adnan tabata by Middle
East analyst thank you very much for
your assessment my pleasure
let me now join DW sterasyl she's our
NATO correspondent in Brussels Thierry
NATO ambassadors are holding an urgent a
meeting today to talk about the fallout
from general Soleimani is killing what
can we expect from this meeting that's
right it will be the first time that
NATO is meeting in the new year and not
under such good circumstances but it's
going to be very important to take the
pulse of NATO allies regarding the NATO
mission in Iraq now that's a non combat
training operation there are several
hundred personnel there who've been
advising and providing assistance to the
Iraqi Ministry of Defence and to the
national security apparatus and that
mission was suspended after the killing
of Qasem Soleimani
and it's not clear what will happen with
those people if they will be asked to
remain in the country proof hoping for a
very temporary suspension depending on
developments on the ground so this will
be important to ask allies what they
intend to do they will also be very
interested in hearing from the United
States on its intentions in the region
there are there's a lot of discomfort
among European allies
no one was fond of Iranian militias but
many European governments are also not
comfortable with targeted killings like
this and obviously the repercussions
that are already being seen for example
with Iran's announcement that it would
no longer adhere to
the nuclear deal so there's a lot to
discuss these are not the kind of
meetings where there will be a statement
at the end but it is possible that we
will hear from NATO secretary-general
Jens Stoltenberg that's unclear at this
point
DD's eteri shows at NATO headquarters in
Brussels thank you very much